I cannot tell you how excited I am for  pitch um so am i right it's one thing to  be the team that called up the first  woman it's another thing to be the team  that pick the wrong woman and turn this  whole thing into a disaster I loved it I  laughed I cried I was in the edge of my  seat the show gonna be filming in  California yeah so I thought it no that  would hell you'd be interested in moving  live with Kelly to California I think  it's shot in New York yeah yeah go  would I go to LA I mean at some point at  some point that I mean if yeah I mean if  his if his if the show goes yeah maybe  an event I mean eventually I would  eventually I would have to go right yeah  yeah and then I could be a Hollywood  wife I want to be far away from you  sometimes maybe she would now I'm joking  it's only it's only a few months yeah  how are things doing as she's searching  for her new co-host oh it's doing great  doing great thank you